うわ
くらあついたついたついたつい
たつい
たこんにちははめ社長
です己止まって
たはいたまに僕やるんですけれども日本
各地にはですね自己物件と言われている
過去にそのお部屋で何か事件があったりと
かなんかこうやばいことがあって訳あり
物件ま事故があった物件で普通の賃貸より
かは安かったりとかなぜか知らないけど誰
もそのお部屋に入居しないとかそういう
ちょっとなんかやばいことがあったお部屋
がこう全国にやっぱりあるんですけど
けれどもそのお部屋に泊まってみようと
いう動画です初め社用は今え東京都の某所
にある自物件のお部屋に来ておりますも
ここ玄関なんですけれどもいきなりやっぱ
ちょっと雰囲気が出てますね玄関もなんか
すごいねこれ自分で持ってきたダンボール
俺の荷物え寝袋となってますうわあなんか
なかなか不思議な汚れ方だな火事があった
んじゃないかみたいなこんな感じになって
ますこわめちゃ怖いなもう過去何回か
止まってるんですけれもあの普通
に自己物件1人で止まるの結構やばいんす
よメンタルがやっ見てください本当に怖い
んですよねた夕方の15時58分16時
ぐらいですねはいえ今から明日の朝まで
このうちに行ってみたいと思いますなんか
埃と汚れがすごすぎてちょっと荷物もあの
ダンボールゴスで置かせていただきます
すいませんなんかね匂いがすごいあかなり
長いで換気してないなというかすごいこっ
てる感じがしますねでは早速家の中を
一通り見ていきたいと思い
ますなゴポゴポいってるなでは見ていき
ますはいでは早速見ていきたいと思います
まずここが玄関
です今もう俺のものだらけになってます
けどこんな感じです
ね靴を抜いで上がりまし
たきますここなん
[音楽]
だろうなんだ風呂バっぽいです
ね
ちょっと待っ
てちょっと待って待って待待待待っ
てやっばうわちょっとマック
やばい吐きそう絶対何かあったね
あ汚いのでちょっと見るの苦手な方ごめん
なさい気をつけて
ください
うわすごい
すごいすごい
天井もすごい
しなんだろうこれライト切るともう廃墟
みたいな雰囲気が出ちゃいますね何かあっ
たならここなのかなわかんない
けどいやこわいや絶対ここでしょ何かあっ
たんだったらじゃあ奥行き
ます
ん
あライト
つく
おおここはなんだなんか引きずった後
みたいなのがあるけどこれなんか絶対
引きずってるよねここうわで扉の奥にも
何かありそうです
ねここがまキッチンかなおそらくキッチン
として使われていた場所だと思い
ますかなり汚れていますね何これ
かなり細長の
棚
はいあ何か収納できそうな感じはあります
ねあすごいお寿になってるんだはいこの
部屋だけじゃなくてなんか奥にもう1部屋
ありそうなんですよね部屋の間取りが結構
すごいね失礼し
[音楽]
ます
おお同じ生りの部屋があり
ますでごめんなさい今めっちゃモザイク
かかってると思うんですけども家の外が
一応撮影許可上映すことができないという
ことでちょっとモザイクになっていますが
とりあえず入ろうか失礼しますうわ匂いが
匂いがすごい匂いがすごいぞなんか部屋の
角は黒くなって
ますすごいねかなりなんか黒ずみが激しい
で一応こういう感じの部屋に
なってますすごいねここの部屋バーンて1
個あって扉の仕切り1つでこっちにもお
部屋がある玄関からお部屋が一直線直列に
なってるから2人以上だと攻めに行くそう
だけど1人で暮らす分にはかなり広い気が
しますここもなんか黒いシミがありますね
これは何
だ
ああクローゼットです
ね
はいはいでさっきも言ったんですけど窓の
外を移すことが禁止されているので
ちょっとこのままだと撮影もしづらい部分
があるのでちょっとダンボールで外の景色
を1回封鎖させてくださいそれだけ
ちょっと今からやっ
ちゃおうとりあえずこれで外は見えなく
なりましたいやかなり怖いすねなんか空気
がやばい止まる準備も一応できました荷物
も運び込みましたでねここで何があったか
のお話をします言える範囲なんですけれど
もこのお家に少し前まで60代男性が
1人暮らしをしていましたでその家族がえ
その男性と連絡を取ろうとしたんです
けれどもなんかある日から連絡が取れなく
なってしまいましてで家を見に行った
ところっていう感じらしいですちょっと何
があったか伏せさせていただきますがで
発見場所その人がどこで見つかったの
かっていうのこの60代の男性が見つかっ
た場所がが脱衣所と浴の
間まさにあそこか一番最初に見たあそこ
ですねなんかちょっと寂しいというか1人
で住んでいた人がこう色々あってちょっと
孤独なこう人生の終わり方をしてしまった
ような場所になってますねでもねなんか
めちゃくちゃ
こことかなんかさめっちゃ引きずった後
あるけどね何なんだろう何か人か何かを
引きずったか何かなのかなずっとなんか
玄関ぐらいでなくなってるんですけど
ずっとこれ続いてますねめっちゃ分かり
やすいよね1回なんかここ経由してる気が
するんだよなこうやっ
てでずっと行ってっていう感じですけどあ
なんかここら辺で玄関に行ったのかこっち
行ったのかわかんないです
けどま何かった場所としてここらしいです
あとこの台所の近くにあるここ開くんです
よ
ね
ううえ何もなかったですここは何もなかっ
たけどここ開くの
よちょっと開けてみていいですか失礼し
ますこは行き
[音楽]
ますん工スペース上げたことないけど
なんか
なんかしまってたんだろうなっていう感じ
です
ねなんか液たいも置けそうな感じはあるな
ただめちゃくちゃ汚れてはいますはい
せっかくなのでこの部屋に入ってみたいと
思います失礼しますいやこれ踏み入れるの
はマジで怖い
な
うやっ
べえ
こわどうやったらこんな汚れ方になるんだ
なんかむけてるしめっちゃお風呂のそも汚
ないし
うわどうもすごいっすねこれはさすがに
トイレもかなり汚れてますね天井も本当に
なんか燃やしたのかななんかすごい何かが
燃えたんじゃないかって
いう状態ですねごめ俺も専門画じゃない
からよくわかんないですけどなんかそんな
雰囲気を感じてます
いやあ俺すごいなこの浴そう入れるやつ
そういないよ多分やばいすね早く出よ無理
はいえ夕方になったので夜ご飯を食べたい
と思いますコンビニで買ってきました
えっと本日のメインディッシュはこちらの
肉あんかけチャーハン結構あの精神的に
参ってるんでちょっとここが強くいきたい
とえ強さを引き出したい強さ引き出すニサ
菌R1後で動画編集するのでそのお供に
コーラアップ組金のスりバーム空ヘはい
以上になりますめっちゃお腹空いてるはず
なんですけども色力がねなんか中途半端に
ないんだよな不思議な精神状態じゃ食べ
させていただきますいただき
ますこの真後ろがお風呂場なんですよここ
が現場
ですあああああやいやいやいやいやいどあ
全部ひっくり返したくなったう
う美味しそうでしょいただき
ますいただき
ます
うん
グッテそう寝た環境がとてもいいアクセに
なっておいしい夜ご飯でしたありがとう
ございますはい夜ご飯を食べ終わってここ
からまもうちょっと寝るまで時間があるの
でやんなきゃいけない仕事とか編集とかし
ながらちょっと夜中になるのを待ちたいと
思い
ます
何物
[音楽]
え待って
何何何
はいえなことはあるここ誰も住んでない
はずなんだけど普通にピンポンなってたぞ
今なんだよマジで誰か来るん
か初め
さょ僕にも取らしてくださいよお前かい
はい
おんで来たちょっとすぐそこまでねいたん
でななんで来たんだ取りたいなと思って僕
も情報嗅ぎつけてマジでピンポンなった時
俺死んだと思ったマジ本当にす
さあなんか取りたいのね自己物件でそうす
ね取りたいすねじゃあいいでしょあそれが
夜俺はマジで1人で出たいから取ったら
じゃ書あわかりましたいや死んだと思った
マジで本当にだとっなんでお前がだ
よこれ1人
あ腐った
[音楽]
カド
私なキリキリ言ってかったキリキリて
バンっ
て
ガ誰も
ね
難しましありがとさねちょっと気がになっ
たよかったですさありがとうはい
ありがとうございます帰りますじゃねはい
あっえもね一瞬でも来てくれて心が助かっ
たではちょ気をつけてはいはめ様気をけて
ください俺だわ本にではおやすみ
み
いや
どんこ何これ
なんかいるのあそこに
え
えこれバグじゃないよね完全に何かい
るっていう反応し
てるえなんかいる
どういう
ことこれ動いてるものとか人間とか飛車体
とかにしか反応しないんですよ
ほらやばいやっぱ人の顔とかに合うんです
よ見る人の顔だって分かるとこうやって
出るんです
けどわけわかんないところにずっと今人の
顔の判定が出てたんですよ今俺の顔だから
こうやって出てる
けどこえ深夜の23時半あと30分ぐらい
に日付が変わりますこっからは完全に朝
まで1人なのでもうちょっとだらっとして
から寝ようと思い
[音楽]
ます
なんか定期的にパキっていう
なはい今もうすぐ2時になりそうです
そろそろ寝ようと思うんですけれどもその
前に最後に1回深夜の間にお部だけぐるっ
と回りたいと思い
ますなま深夜と言っても行くところは1
箇所なんですけど
ねそこだけ見てその後は寝ようと思います
やっぱ行くとしたらここだよ
ないやこは
夜ってまた雰囲気違うんだよな行き
ます
[音楽]
特に大丈夫かな
あえさすがに水道の音だよなさすがに水道
の音なってくれ
よ
何今
のパキってっ
たやにより部屋のきしみということにし
たいやっぱこの跡がすごいよな本当
に100%何か引きずったもん足か何か
わかんない
けど寒い寒いけどちゃんと寝ない
とえ待っ
て怖いジで寝るのか寝るしかないんだ
なよしじゃあこれで寝ます何かあっ
たら教えてくださいおやすみ
なさい
[音楽]
玄関の天気消してくる
か
[音楽]
1人暮らしで何もない方にライフハックな
んですけどコンビニで買ったトイレット
ペーパーを開けずに4ロール入ってるやつ
に買った新品のバスタオルを巻く
とそこそこ使い心地のいい枕になりますお
やすみ
なさいこは寝心地が悪い生きた心地がし
ないだがそれ
OK
JA
おはようござい
ます朝5時ですさすがにこの状況かは寝れ
ないな起きましょうかこの部屋の空気が
悪いのか衛生的に良くないかわかんない
ですけど
めっちゃ息がしづらいです絶対誇り吸い
すぎてる気が
する
それか別の何かかちょっとわかんないです
けどとてもじゃないですけど寝れた環境で
はないですねもうちょちょっと粘ってみた
んですけども6時ぐらいでちょっと帰らせ
てもらいますまあなんかそういう霊的な
ものではないと思いますけど普通に環境が
衛星的にもう空気が全然違いすぎててと
呼んでてなんか匂いもすごいし俺逆によく
今まで入れたなって思ってますちょ本当に
体調崩しそうなのとなんか呼吸が深くでき
ないんでちょっと先
に一応朝までは入れたのでここで帰らせて
もらいますうん不思議なお部屋でしたね
そうなん足音が異常に多いのよ周りに人が
住んでるのもしてるんですけどもなんか
その日になんないぐらいやけに足音が
聞こえた印象があり
ます
[音楽]
H